[Music]
right when in finland
we eat a burger but this is not just any
burger this is a reindeer burger okay so
i forget the sort of cuddly
reindeer image at christmas and think
about a delicious protein that is a
staple here in finland i've got some
ground reindeer with some smoked
reindeer okay so two thirds ground
and one third smoked and that smokiness
is gonna really sort of give it a nice
delicious twist now salt pepper
there's hardly any fat in reindeer and
that's why such a staple here so i'm
gonna crack an egg in there
and get that mixed up and
a teaspoon of olive oil now mix that in
okay
and you'll see
how that comes together
beautifully you want to get that
really nice
combination
of
protein
and that smoky flavor
now from there
form that up
keep it nice and thin not gonna go too
thick for the pate because
it cooks so quickly now once you've
formed that
over into the pan
ronnie like you like reindeer [ __ ]
always in the middle of the forest
get that pan really nice and hot
oil in
generous little oil
okay
lift that up
now
in she goes
beautiful
now
one of the most exciting things about
this part of finland are these woods
because we've got the most amazing
chanterelle in there i'm gonna put the
mushrooms in there as well now look okay
mushrooms in there a touch of salt
pepper
okay
just super careful on the cook
it's a
beautiful protein
so be very very careful let's get it a
little bit more
exciting in that pan
onions
[Music]
okay
get them in there as well
and look
and now
the butter
and this is where it goes into orbit
okay
now the flavor
so beautiful reindeer
is incredibly lean okay
so you have to be super careful
i'm cooking it
turn the tame
and give that a quick turn
beautiful
look at that
mushrooms are sauteing beautifully
onions
frying
so good from there
and we've got these beautiful slices
of gouda
which i'm going to start putting over
the burger
okay
[Music]
the gourd is going to give it that nice
richness look at those
beautiful
now
take those
mushrooms out
beautiful
from there
tear them out
and then literally
cover
that pan there
so that cheese starts to melt okay
now the flavor
from these mushrooms
and those grilled onions
are incredible
really incredible
now for the exciting part
quick toast from the bun
beautiful
this is where the burger starts to take
on a completely different level because
toasting the bun is so important that
gives a nice base and structure
the reindeer is super lean so you have
to be very careful you don't overcook it
otherwise it goes really dry the gouda
gives that really nice richness the
secret here now is toasting that bun
both sides and look that gives that
really nice crispy base so we can start
building those layers
on that's my base and that's my top
now
i've got
a spoon
of mayonnaise
there
a spoon
of
mustard
on there lettuce
and now
those onions
and that incredible
wild mushroom
cooked in the same pan like that we've
got all the same flavors
and it just gets more and more decadent
a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
i'll save some onions from top
the next bit
and i slice the tomato
nice and
thin
tomatoes
that's my base
gouda is melting beautifully
so beautiful
gouda gowda
whatever it takes your fancy fresh
butter at the end
i'm going to baste that
off
we sit that on
and then top that
with our grilled onions
so tasty
and then boom
that
is a delicious
reindeer finish burger now if you
enjoyed that recipe please click the
link below and if you missed uncharted
then please watch on catch up on disney
plus
[Music]